an auditorium has ten seats in the first
row 14 in the second 18 in the third and
so on the auditorium has a total of 18
rows how many seats are there in total
if you don't understand the problem at
first sight try drawing a rough sketch
if this is the stage they have told us
that the first row has 10 seats the
second has 14 the third has 18 and so on
and there are 18 rows in all this is
nothing but an arithmetic sequence the
difference between any two continuous
rows is constant the sequence will be 10
14 18 and so on this is an AP we have
been asked for the total number of seats
in the auditorium it means we have been
asked for the sum of the sequence what
is the sum of the terms of an AP it will
be n over 2 multiplied by first term
plus the last term here n will be the
last term number what is the first term
we call it a and here it's 10 and how do
we find the last term there are 18 rows
the nth term of an AP is given by a plus
n minus 1 times D to find the last term
we just substitute 18 in place of n we
get the last term as 78 we have n the
first term and the last term with this
we can easily find the sum n over 2 will
be 18 over 2
the first term is 10 and the last one is
78 this bracket will equal 10 plus 78
this is n over 2 and this is first term
plus the last term solving this gives us
792 there are 792 seats in the
auditorium let's quickly
view what we did based on the
arrangement of the number of seats we
realized that it is an arithmetic
progression as we were asked for the
number of seats we were indirectly asked
to find the sum of this AP with 18 terms
and using the formula for the sum of
terms in an AP we calculated the number
of seats here's another interesting
problem the sequence is given to us as 4
raised to n and we are told that the
16th term of the sequence is this big
number is this true or false what do you
think
don't take a random guess think an
answer ok if you actually try to
calculate 4 raised to 16 you would have
stopped Midway I am sure the number will
be huge so how do we know if this is
true or false ok let's try to find the
first few terms of the sequence the
first term is 4 raised to 1 that equals
4 the second term is 4 raised to 2 and
that equals 16 we still can't be sure
about whether this is true or false okay
so the third term is 4 raised to 3 that
equals 64 erm still no clue the fourth
term is 4 raise to 4 256 now maybe we
are getting closer did you get it let's
solve for two more terms and you will
surely get a hint the fifth term is
1,024 and the sixth one is 4096 now can
you say if the answer is true or false
come on you should get it now look at
the unit digits of every term it's
either 4 or 6 4 6 4 6 4 6 and so on
no matter what the power of 4 is the
unit's digit will either be 4 or so
this answer is definitely false what
about the sequence 3 raise to n does it
also have a cyclic kill pattern in its
units digits the first four terms are 3
9 27 and 81 and these are the next four
terms do you see a pattern yes a pattern
of three nine seven one similarly for
seven raised to n the pattern of digits
in the unit's place will be seven nine
three and one there are a couple of more
things we can deduce from this we can
say that even powers of four have six as
the unit's digit and odd powers have
four as the unit's digit if we asked for
the unit's digit of three raised to 36
we can be sure it's one if it is of the
form three raised to 4 n then the unit's
digit will be one so whenever you're
asked for the large exponent of a number
it will probably pertain to this concept
you